so dice tricks again this is from martin
gardner's book
this is an absolute classic i think
three dice d6s and i've got my little
blindfold because i'm going to pretend
i can't see i actually can't see now i
could cheat i could look through this
thing
but i'm not right and the point i'm
going to show you is that i don't need
to cheat there's a way through
so i'm going to ask you to roll the dice
i'm going to blindfold myself from now
on
can you grab those three d6s and roll
them for me so
i'm going to ask you to do some adding
up i know that's pressure but okay i can
do that i can do that okay
i've rolled them can you add up the
three numbers you can see yes keep this
total running in your head obviously i
can't see them now
choose one of the dice okay and check
the number on the bottom show the camera
and add that on
that make sense yep okay can you re-roll
that one
and add the one on top of that one that
you just re-rolled onto your total as
well
yeah and now if you want to leave the
totals pointing up but like
put the dice together so i can't tell
which one got re-rolled or anything and
the point is that i can't
see anything about which dicey revolved
and i missed the re-rolling business yep
all done yep i'm gonna take my blindfold
off now but i've missed the crucial
stages
and you're thinking of a number in your
head there's no way i can know that the
number is 16.
except i do because it's amazing wow
that's pretty cool i'm impressed that
you're impressed
let's try it again i mean like like all
magic tricks as we will say
uh if to know how trick works you try
and repeat the trick i'm just going to
cover my eyes this time
are you having to re-roll again yep you
can be thinking about how it's possible
for me to know this and i'll show my
eyes
all right here we go okay
yeah add them up yeah yep get it right
pick a dice
you don't have to pick the same one as
you picked last time and check the
number on the bottom and add that onto
your total
yep and re-roll that one
and then group them so i can't really
tell which one got re-rolled there's no
way i can see it and i'm going to look
at these now
so you have a number in your head yep
and that number
is definitely 12. yep good
all right i mean the audience can't see
brady's brain
worrying like it somehow involves the
number seven
go on yeah wait could good conjecture
i need a bell to ring conjecture is the
number seven involved why do you say
seven i know that some people will be
shouting that a bit because opposite
sides of a dice add up to seven does it
help
well the fact you made me turn one of
them the other way around makes me think
it must
just use your conjecture we're kind of
working backwards here like check these
three dice again
there is a difference of seven there
between what between the number
you said and what they add up to do you
remember what happened the first time
no should we do it again oh you're all
right yeah all right well
i'm going to watch this time all right
here we go here we go
so that adds up to 12. i agree
if i take this one and add two
that comes to fourteen
yeah and then you re-roll seventeen
and at this point i take my blindfold
off and i've missed all the crucials oh
look and that's ten so you add seven
you had seven if i tell you your
conjecture is correct
yes now you need to tell me why
and like all magic tricks when you spot
this i guarantee you'd be like ah
seriously why did i not see that a
million miles off
oh let's let's all right let's let's
let's
okay so there we go that adds up to ten
i agree
adds up to ten that's unchanged
add three takes it to thirteen
plus six nineteen
and i can see just that twelve and that
twelve add seven gets you
up to nineteen what
what happened i don't know what happened
it's like all magic tricks again it's
misdirection right
you're at the heart of the problem
you've got the key but the the way the
trick is presented
direct your attention away from the
crucial thing i will make this really
obvious to you now i think
when i take my blindfold off this is all
i can see so what have i missed
i've missed this one having its first
roll what was it i can't remember
yeah it doesn't actually matter does it
because whatever it was
you add the bottom number to it ah so
the first roll was irrelevant
well it's not irrelevant what matters is
the dice are set up in the way that you
know dice is set up and this is the key
opposite numbers of a die d6 after seven
but that means the first roll
is that and that and that's always seven
it was always going to be whatever the
sum of those two is
plus seven plus that you can't see the
seven anymore
no i know it's seven yeah that's seven's
gone you know in the pub when you're
doing this when we're allowed back in
pubs so you do that you glance and you
look away and then
basically you're panicking about trying
to add seven to the number you've just
seen on the table
it can be done it sounds difficult i
know genuinely it's difficult under
pressure
but all you've got to do is add seven to
that because you know that the roll and
the bottom
before the re-roll is gonna be seven
that's it like it's just seven
but the obfuscation technical word for
the misdirection
is is neat enough and a lot of people
know a lot of dice tricks that use the
property of the seven but this is one of
the neatest ones because it's right
there in front of you if you break it
down
but the way the re-roll and the
performer claiming they didn't see the
re-roll
is the misdirection that you need to
make the seven
obvious but it doesn't need a lot of
practice to learn and
you can adjust it you can do it with
with four dice you just gotta adjust
what you expect to happen you could ask
them to re-roll to them hey
the world's your oyster and the nice
thing about magic in maths is that once
you've got the maths taped
you've got the sort of creativity of the
performance of the magic and the
misdirection and the story
to be creative about so my advice is to
do it with
four dice to it with different dice
although there's a problem with this one
octahedral dice five on that side on the
opposite side
has a six that's to eleven one on that
side opposite side is a two that's the
three
this die does not have a consistent sum
on opposite faces
and i don't know why they could have
made it so it
so it did but for whatever reason the
factory producing these is not doing it
what they are doing with the
the other diet and i was checking some
other diets they seem to do it
for the dodecahedron dice that does seem
to have a consistent sun
and the icosahedron but not the
octahedron um
and we could find a tetrahedron as well
but then we have a problem
that doesn't have opposite sides so my
advice is
don't use that one uh you can get away
with those if you
figure out what the opposite sum is it's
not hard but watch out for octahedral
dice they seem to be made in two
versions and this version is one that
won't work for our little trick
there you go that's the three dice trick
this one like it feels like it's rigged
against you
i did it right and that's the lack of a
dice roll that's why games with
randomness are interesting to be the
second state
okay this flap is below what he's
holding
now you cannot go from the first state
to the second state because he's in the
way if it
wasn't true there would be only finitely
many exceptions
did we do it am i did i not make it
you got it i got it oh thank god